hello and welcome to conan o'brien needs
a friend
i am your host conan o'brien although
you can call me just conan
you know i'm getting very self-conscious
about the intros because i've been
listening
i never listened to a lot of other
podcasts and now i'm listening to other
podcasts and
they're a little more formal when they
open the show and i'm realized that i'm
not
and i think that's why i just started so
formally which is not my way usually i
don't think about it at all and that's a
better way to go i've noticed in the
first line you do
you go formal right out of the gate and
then immediately lose it
the next line you speak i was going to
say i agree i i think you
start off very like hello this is conan
o'brien needs a friend
i'm conan o'brien it's like
you have a voice that you do and then
you quickly snap out of it yes yes
because
i i get this
idea in my head i when i hear other
people do podcasts
they start with this kind of authority
and
i don't i feel like i shouldn't i don't
have that i don't know does that does
that make sense
yeah you go from like 70s radio dj to
basement podcaster
well because i i forget that i'm what it
is we're doing
yeah at the beginning matt when you say
okay conan get us started you can go now
three two one
it's very natural that's that's not a
natural place to start from
yeah so i go hello and welcome to conan
o'brien and i'm like welcome
to pbs newshour tonight we'll be talking
about the ancient incas did they really
have their own calendar you know and
that
we're not that's not us no i know it's
not us but when we
start and i'm on my own for about i
would say it only lasts for about eight
seconds
but that's what i do then i realize i'm
just with you knuckleheads and what are
we doing
and i really i remember my own absurdity
as a human being and then
the next thing you know we're just
talking like this and i'm saying
and whatever whatever else but i
realized just now i don't know why but
this is the first time i realized that i
do get into my head when i do an
introduction sometimes
yeah you do it so formally that it makes
me feel like
wait are we more important than i know
no trust me we're not no
no it goes away i just you know i laugh
every time
every time you have a serious voice it
makes me laugh yeah do you notice that
sona and i share a look on the zoom
every time look checking in with each
other going he's doing it again
hello and welcome hello but so it should
just be more like hey there going to
brian that kind of thing
well that's that's a little too
dismissive i should just be you well
see no it's it's it's this is
ah man this uh
you can't get in your you can't get in
your head you know you just can't get in
your head and now what i've heard is
that's too formal
and that's too informal okay now i'm in
my head even further than i was when we
started
you know yeah so nothing i do let's try
a couple of really right now a couple of
just give me a couple just point to me
and say go or action and i'll give you
let's do like three or four in a row and
see if we can find it
sounds good three two one go it's
colonel bryan needs a friend um
another one quickly quickly three two
one go
have we got a show for you quickly again
three two one go hi it's conan you know
me
the same guy you've been chilling with
since 1993.
that's pretty good that was pretty good
i haven't changed
uh still the guy you didn't like then
and you grew slowly to like last year
how about that
that's not bad but i think you should
just open with a kakaroo
o'brien there you go welcome to conan
o'brien yeah or maybe i mean that's the
other thing too is we're not we should
have a morning zoo energy where you and
sona are making a lot of noise and you
have
all right you guys knuckleheads quiet
down we got a lot of traffic on the 101
freeway and today we're talking to a sex
therapist i'm looking through the glass
right now she's brought nine dildos
we're getting a call right now let's
it's bee's man bees man's out he's
bothering women on ventura boulevard
what's up bees man i just bothered with
some ladies
yeah bees man go man go
let's get the sex therapist in here
that's the kind of show we need to be
doing